let's hear from some more people via
Discord davidpackman.com Discord let's
go to James from Texas if you're with us
James I would love to hear what's on
your mind today
yeah uh long time fan can you hear me
yes I can
absolutely all right long time fan thank
you when I first discovered you it was a
interview with Peter Joseph oh okay
remember Peter yes I do the Zeitgeist
Movement guy yes excellent so my
question to you is Peter Joseph Jacques
Fresco uh these two individuals
published multiple films and Peter wrote
a book and in which they've discussed
the decline of society based on our
current economic model
that produces the negative results we're
seeing now as in more mass shootings
more mental illness
Etc do you believe that this is the case
that the economic system we're in right
now is
incapable of lasting and is going to
continue producing these negative
so incapable of incapable of lasting is
different then we'll continue to produce
negative externalities so here this is a
huge topic James and a really great one
um I uh so let's see where to even start
of course
the economic system within which we live
influences our daily lives in many ways
and in the same way that you can say
well the economic system allows us
access to things we like cheap stuff
diversity of food all these different
things right things things that we think
are good Innovation all these things it
also creates negative issues we haven't
yet fully dealt with the negative
externality of pollution that industry
produces there's too much inequality we
have crime we have mental illness a
Health Care System that's not working
all of these things right on both sides
of the Ledger are partially a result of
the economic system a lot of times sort
of like typical
grad school Master's level analyzes kind
of end there and they often end up at
like well I don't know capitalism is the
problem and like I guess maybe for some
people socialism would be the solution
or for people that me it'd be social
democracy or whatever the case may be I
do think that understated in some of
those analyzes are the impacts of what
we know from sociology and psychology
and hard sciences and all these other
things now those who say no no no no no
no
the economic system influences all of
that our psychology and Society is
influenced by the economic system yes it
is but it's not only influenced by that
so my view is I think people like Peter
Joseph and the late Jacques Fresco
have very interesting things to say
about the way that many systems affect
the way any one of us lives day to day
what I don't like is once or I don't
agree with is when some people become
too focused solely on the economic
analysis and I don't think we should
minimize the economic analysis but we
should make it much more robust than
just that
excellent and um one more question are
you planning to do interviews again and
would you consider having Peter back on
after Zeitgeist sport comes out we we do
like 15 interviews a month or something
like that 10 interviews a month yeah so
it's not we're it's not considering we
do interviews all the time and I would
be glad to have Peter back on the show
sure
excellent I'm looking forward to it all
right James from Texas thank you very
much for the call I appreciate that